all right so my reviews if the
Christopher Nolan Batman's are a
long-overdue so here we go Batman Begins
otherwise known as the CPR of a
franchise now when Batman Begins was
first lady to be made I heard it was
gonna be by the director of memento to
which I thought that's interesting but
it might be just what we need
and it was because let's face it Batman
died in the hands of and now we have
Batman again so Batman Begins is the
story of Bruce Wayne who after the death
of his parents or murder of his parents
transforms himself from really angry
pissed-off rich kid to the Batman and I
was really surprised as to how much
depth they gave the character in this
movie before Batman Begins I just
thought Batman as a vigilante end of
story
in this movie it shows it goes deeper
than that I mean he's a pissed-off rich
kid yeah for sure but then Liam Neeson
who plays Ducard his trainer gives him a
path and trains him to be a ninja yeah
Batman is a ninja oh yeah and he teaches
them if you're a vigilante you can be
killed and destroyed but if you're a
symbol if you're something bigger than
that you don't die even if you die you
don't die kind of and the acting in this
movie everyone plays their roles
perfectly and there are a lot of people
to mention so here we go first of all
oscar-winning actor Christian Bale as
Bruce Wayne / Batman absolutely perfect
and he had to play three roles in this
movie the Bruce Wayne where he interacts
with Alfred you know he's just himself
he's a guy then he plays the Batman
that's when he unleashes all his anger
he's like the devil he just freaks
criminals out he really plays mind games
- he's just preys on their fear like I
said he's a ninja so to the people to
the criminals he's like disappearing
from their going to their that's what
they see anyway
that would freak me out Andy plays the
mask of Bruce Wayne which is the Bruce
Wayne that everyone thinks he should be
I mean let's face it Bruce Wayne's been
gone training for like five years
everyone thought he was dead he comes
back and then this Batman character also
pops into Gotham at the same time
Gotham's really rich Prince comes back
rich guy who could probably I don't know
be Batman so he has to act like he's
just irresponsible doesn't give a
it's all about women cars money dresses
up like a bad clearly is it so no one
would possibly ever think that that guy
is actually Batman that's really cool I
never really thought of that before I
would have a bat suit if I were rich are
you kidding me you betcha and then we
have Cillian Murphy as the Scarecrow
Jonathan crane I always thought he was
perfect casting for that role but if
you're a scarecrow fanboy this movie
might piss you off
I thought they used the Scarecrow in a
way that's really relevant but they
don't use him that much it's not like
the Scarecrow show or anything like that
so if you really want to see a lot of
scarecrow you might be a little
irritated in fact that's the one
complaint I've ever heard about this
movie so the Scarecrow is not used
enough nonetheless he's the perfect
Jonathan crane props to the Scarecrow
then Liam Neeson has Ducard Bruce
Wayne's trainer perfect also Liam
Neeson's a good actor he's like the
voice of what God and Narnia and he is
the voice of God in here as far as I'm
concerned but at the end of this movie
though you're like Liam Neeson was
perfect for that role anyone would agree
and Michael Caine is Alfred offered some
comic relief without taking away from
the movie being an old comic relief guy
that's a tough line to walk because if
you overdo it you're just gonna be some
annoying old do poor people are gonna be
like dude get off the screen so we can
get back to the Batman please but
Michael Caine was perfect and glad he's
gonna be in the third one I can't see
another Alfred at this point I can and
another old awesome dude in this movie
who's also the voice of God in another
movie Morgan Freeman as Lucius Fox
Lucius Fox is the guy he's kind of like
Bruce Wayne's insider into Wayne Corp
you would think that Bruce Wayne would
not need an insider at Wayne Court but
he does and the whole time you're like
does he know he's Batman does he not
know he's Batman you don't really know
it never says he never goes up to Bruce
Wayne he's like I know your secret you
dick now pay me money
so most us like this plausible
deniability thing it's like yeah I know
what you do you know I know what you do
we leave it at that and yes I will help
you I think in Vicki Vale knew and she
was like a reporter so there that is
pretty sure Morgan Freeman can keep a
secret more than a blonde reporter check
and Gary Oldman as Jim Gordon was
perfect the guy's a very diverse actor
he can nail anything and he nails Jim
Gordon as in the acting he's like
Batman's unspoken partner in crime I
know some people are like oh you need to
bring Robin into it at one point but you
don't he has Jim Gordon perfect partner
right there and even rocks the mustache
so Batman Begins is a badass movie about
a guy stepping up to do what's right to
reinvent himself to become more than a
vigilante he would become an
incorruptible symbol of hope as he goes
on his quest to bring his city back from
the wreckage of its damnation is about
stepping up and doing what's right there
is a sweet line in the movie where Katie
Holmes says that explains it right there
so Batman Begins is awesome tacular it
has to be Christopher Nolan brought back
a franchise from the dead in fact Nolan
izing something is actually a term now
like you know Mortal Kombat rebirth is
Nolan izing mortal kombat taking
something unrealistic and making it
realistic
Nolan izing something so have you seen
Batman Begins what did you think of it
what is your favorite superhero movie of
all time
that's a good question comment below let
me know and if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]